when you're young and you get this it's
like you do see other women as threats
as intimidation as they were the ones
that were bullying me it wasn't the boys
it was always the girls so then i had
like i held on to the insecurity so any
time i saw an incredible woman it just
became a reflection of how incompetent i
felt that i was my book the difference
between jealousy and envy envy can be
something that you see someone have but
it inspires you right it's like well if
freaking danica danica can do it and so
can i you know and she's come from
nowhere and by golly i can do it too but
that's freaking empowering and envy can
be beautiful but jealousy to your point
can tell you apart you just feel worse
about yourself being around that person
and you know it is something that you
strive for but it really just reflects
why you haven't gotten it versus which i
use now is like a beautiful inspiration
and um so yeah i think growing up i
realized that i was insecure with myself
it was actually my own feelings that i
had about myself that were really
echoing how i saw other women and it
wasn't until i started working on my own
mindset and how i felt about myself and
taking ownership over stepping up to the
plate with bad in hand and swinging as
hard as i can even if i miss that gave
me the encouragement to be like how did
she do it that's amazing maybe i can do
it too
wow
bold and brave and
really difficult like i don't think
people understand how hard it is to even
get to the point that you can start to
see yourself
in an equation
like i think most people go through life
pretty asleep to this dynamic
and so how did you wake up
this is one of these this is literally
why i wrote the book radical confidence
because the point was is that girl i
spent eight years what i call stuck
and i call it i was in purgatory the
mundane i didn't hit rock bottom when
you've hit
rock bottom and you're like there's
nowhere else to go well i may as well
try for this and in that effort to try
you then succeed so many people i've
interviewed were there but for me i
never hit rock bottom so i ended up
spending eight years of my life in
purgatory my life was just mundane
enough i had a roof over my head i had a
husband that loved me and so each day
because i wasn't in desperation i was
actually talking myself out of changing
my life because i would say to myself
well who do you think you are like being
ungrateful for not having
you know a career that you're excited
about when you've got a roof over your
head and you know how ungrateful you
lisa that you're saying you don't want
to put clothes out for your husband
anymore because i literally spent eight
years taking care of my husband i was a
supportive wife i was putting his
clothes out for him and putting his
lunch and dinner out every single day
that was my purpose in life
and i started to feel like this wasn't
the life i wanted this was the life my
parents told me i was gonna have this
was the life my grandparents being greek
orthodox told me i was gonna have but it
wasn't the life i wanted and every time
that feeling of like but this isn't the
dream i had
i would convince myself but you should
be grateful that you have a husband that
loves you and this is where i kind of
found myself in this place of gratitude
is beautiful when you have a
slip into a victim mentality and you're
like why me being grateful is amazing it
really does highlight all the beautiful
things that are happening in your life
but it also for me ended up keeping me
stuck because i was so still talking
about how grateful i was i ended up not
saying hang on a minute yes you can be
grateful for having a husband of your
dreams you can be grateful for having a
beautiful home and yet you can be
totally utterly miserable and want more
in other parts of your life and one
doesn't dictate the other and so that
realization girl hit me like a freaking
ton of bricks and it was quest that
pulled me out of shaking me awake damn
that was awesome i think that's so cool
of you to say because so many people
uh you know gratitude is everything and
just practice that every day and what an
epiphany
did was there a breaking moment or was
this like a culmination of time that all
the sudden just made you turn around and
go
what the hell am i doing
yeah it's this is the thing i wish it
was a lightning rod moment and i can say
everyone at home that's listening wait
for this moment and you're good the
problem wasn't it wasn't and just like
it was stepping stones small little
decisions that i made for eight years
that kept me stuck it ended up being
small little decisions that ended up
taking me into a life that i didn't
realize was possible and that's why i
wrote the book is like how do i break
people of that notion of what is
possible and what we have the right to
ask for and that was the thing i started
to notice people saying lisa i want i
want confidence like you i want your
confidence and i'd be like who are they
talking to i'm not confident like you
should hear the voice in my head about
telling me all the things that i'm bad
at i would look around like oh
they think i'm confident but what they
just see is someone that moves forward
and they think it's confidence they
think i feel good about myself and so if
i can shake that feeling of confidence
and help people pivot it's not about
feeling amazing all the time it's about
saying i want confidence to do this find
out what this is and now focus on that
so like for you right and not i want to
like you know like put myself in your
position but like i want to be the
fastest you know race car driver in the
world it's like okay like that's the
goal not hey i want confidence to get in
the car how do you take those steps
first of all number one again i'm not
going to pretend that i know but number
one is like get in the car and hold the
steering wheel number two go at 10 miles
an hour number three go at 50 miles an
hour it becomes these stepping stones to
get to that goal but if all you're doing
is looking at that audacious goal and
saying i want the confidence to do that
you don't get started so the whole
thinking to me is how do we start to
step out of and back to your question of
how did i end up making that pivot in my
life it was small little decisions that
i had made that i realized i'm stuck
and then this isn't the life i want and
that then led to
i just want to be happy what does happy
mean i don't freaking know but right now
it isn't what we're doing
and that caused me to say but what would
happiness look like and so i said to my
husband i don't care how much money
we've made on paper at the time we were
just chasing money this was before quest
he was working so many hours and he was
coming home and he was really miserable
and so i said i'm fed up with chasing
money i just want a happy husband i want
a happy relationship
what would that look like and that
started the catalyst of tom going in and
quitting his job as he quit his job his
business partner said oh my god we're
unhappy too
let's actually sell the company and do
something else that notion then started
if we were doing something else what
would we enjoy doing
let's try the protein bar company that
was the idea that came to it and then
tom came home and he's like babe do you
mind just helping out because i just
thought that as long as i'm supporting
my husband right now that's my future so
when he said we're starting a protein
bar company because we're unhappy will
you help us of course i'll help babe i'm
a good greek wife
and so but what we didn't expect is the
company grew at 57 000
i went from helping my husband out on
the living room floor shipping bars
weighing peanut butter on home scales
and we were renting a kitchen by the
hour with like knives and rolling pins
to you know within two years we had 10
000 square feet of space i had 40
employees and you know working just
underneath me alone half of them had
criminal backgrounds but they were
incredible people but being five foot
one i had to every day basically show up
to be like you're gonna let these people
push you around are you gonna you know
be able to lead and that continuous
facing myself every day not knowing my s
not having skills learning every day
saying okay lisa you can go into this
not knowing it and learn or you can say
yeah this is too scary but if i don't do
it i lose my house because our house was
up for collateral
so
yeah but in that process right it didn't
give me the luxury of saying well i
don't know how to run a team i don't
even know how to you know um to build a
a warehouse i didn't give myself the
luxury and every time i didn't give
myself the luxury
and i found had an obstacle that i then
figured out
it gave me that like
validation within myself that for so
many years i was searching for outside
of myself i was searching for my husband
to come home every day and validate me
because i made nice dinner right i was
waiting for validation for my parents to
tell me i was a good wife i was waiting
for validation from so many extra
external people or things
that having that pivot putting myself in
these situations where i didn't think i
was capable and then going oh my god i'm
actually capable to figure it out
gave me that idea of what else am i
capable of
and that was the thing of i don't know
what i'm capable of i don't know where
i'm going but the idea that who i am
today does not dictate who i can be
tomorrow was so intoxicating
that i was like i need to do more of
this and that's where i started to pivot
and say what life do i actually want and
by golly i'm gonna freaking demand it of
myself
yeah you and tom are such like
go-getters you guys are crazy
um because i know he has so much of this
in him too um
this feels like the book is called
radical confidence but this feels like a
whole lot of radical honesty it really
is like thinking outside the box and
being honest with yourself is 100 a
massive key and the reason why i called
it radical confidence was going back to
everyone was just like at least how do
you get your confidence and i'm like
it's so not confidence like confidence
is when you feel great and you've got
swagger and you're like yeah i got this
i'm so far from that danica i'm like oh
my god lisa what on earth are you doing
you have the audacity to try writing a
book you've never bloody written a book
before but hey you know what i don't
have the confidence but i'm going to
freaking figure it out and i'm going to
take all of my insecurities all of my
inadequacies because i am inadequate to
writing a book because i've never
written a book before and give myself
the grace to frickin learn and freaking
stumble and literally every time i fall
on the floor lisa you're going to give
yourself the beauty and the grace to
pick yourself up that is radical
confidence that's going in not
pretending like you know everything but
saying i've got a tool belt
and i'm going to use whatever tool i
need in this moment when i'm scared to
move forward with radical confidence
[Music]